[Music]
it's troubling times troubling times
right my friends nope my life's great
mm-hmm same thing that was a very quick
note
i guess we shouldn't talk about this
topic i don't like troubling
the us troops are to deploy to eastern
europe amid the ukraine crisis how did
we [ __ ] call it because i said
if someone else was in office right now
there's gonna be a new war
somewhere always we need to make money
yeah yeah
the defense industry uh needs to pay for
some things okay
that's how it works the funny thing is
is the the leader of ukraine was like
can you all people in the west stop
talking about russia invading us because
you're making it worse yeah making it
worse right and i don't know if that's
true or not whatever it is true russia
has i think 60 or 70 000 troops on the
border and we're sending 3 000.
so you know that those troops
they just got there
a couple of years ago
so
it's pretty scary
it's pretty scary but you know our
troops are super troops that's why for
every one of our troops it represents a
hundred of theirs we call them spartans
wasn't ukraine going through a civil war
like several years ago because of this
there were one side that were uh nato
and u.n uh sympathizers the other ones
were more russian sympathizers and
within ukraine there was some kind of
civil war they they had photos too of
the airport of like after they had a
battle there it looked like [ __ ] call
of duty [ __ ] like it was [ __ ] up right
yeah and then um i don't know right now
it's kind of kind of i don't know what's
going on because you know hunter biden
does have uh interests in a few
companies in ukraine so he's an honest
guy hey listen his dad said so don't
[ __ ] on hunter biden you guys
he's a prolific artist and he's just
making his [ __ ] everybody has a grind
is hunter the one with the crack pipe
mm-hmm yeah i was saying right allegedly
yeah that's in his past
it could have been oregano we don't know
it's a photo his dad said it was in the
past dude stop bringing it up yeah i'm
not bad sorry guys yeah it was like five
years ago that's so long ago dude i want
to name my son hunter
hall yeah hunter hall and then i could
buy him only helly hansen clothes so
it'll be h everywhere
that's pretty everything is hnh
[Laughter]
so president joe biden has formally
approved the deployment of 3 000 u.s
troops to poland germany and romania i
can't believe jk news called it
did we not it's [ __ ] hilarious and
people were like you're
confused that'll never happen yeah cool
they want more wars go figure didn't we
talk about this during the time when we
were uh setting up missiles out there in
eastern europe and then uh it was
getting pressure on
russia yeah we were talking about how
you know they're trying to get us into a
war with russia
years ago and then people were going you
guys are conspiracy that's i mean yeah
steven duke can stop being conspiracy
theorists
well also because trump was so unlikable
in the comments trump was so unlikable
right yeah that when the mainstream
media and the military-industrial
complex tried to conspire sentiment
toward anti-russia he immediately got
ahead of that and met with putin and
then they turned around and said oh he
loves dictators because
if you guys remember during that time
they were trying to talk about how north
korea
was developing a missile
on the uh to hit the west coast and
there was that scare and then he went to
go meet with un and then there was no
more news after that so i think like
these different plays kept us away from
war during that whole time somehow we
had like four years of no war for once
out of how many years like it's been 22
at least dude as well did you guys see
that video of uh jan saki talking to the
reporter and and she was uh giving
questions like why are we even doing
this like the american
public opinions like we shouldn't even
be over there
and then jen saki was like you're
un-american you don't know what you're
talking about i'm sympathizing yeah
russian sympathizer i was like yo this
is crazy right now the way they're
justifying how has the left got in here
yeah that's what blows my mind right
it's like dude how are you at the place
where you hate russia so much you're
like we should go to work but the left
was anti-fucking wolf they still are the
real ones still are the real ones so i
don't understand there's a corporatist
democrat wing going on that for some
reason can't wait for the next conflict
because they're all just they can't wait
to [ __ ] all over russia and look i'm not
saying russ is great who gives a [ __ ] i
just don't want to go to war with those
we don't do we don't need to be here
that exactly right
you know exactly you know for for the
longest time the right was the war
hawking [ __ ] they still are the
christian right yeah except for like the
new the new right right like the
influencer right or whatever but
the thing is i never would have thought
it would come from the mouths of
democrats that we want war
well they all voted for it and with iraq
too like it was it's a you know you have
a uniparty right like
they all work together it's a
corporatist wing we all know that like
the reason why you know
eisenhower warned us about the
military-industrial complex is because
he saw what was going on the money that
is being made
for both parties well they both vote us
into war so people go like like look
george w got some of the shittiest wars
ever agreed everyone agrees but both
houses of congress voted for that work
yeah 96
everybody voted for it except for dennis
kucinich a [ __ ] hero who's a democrat
and there was another there was a
republican at the time i don't remember
his name but like that was about it and
a lot of people are like well they're
going into these countries where they
don't even benefit i'm like okay that's
not how the military makes money we
don't make money from these poor
countries invading them it that's we
never made money off of afghanistan or
iraq uh maybe the pharmaceuticals in
afghanistan if you want to believe the
conspiracy about the poppy fields but
sounds insane but
the real money
the real money is made from the u.s
citizen because the military industrial
complex they get contracts from the
government so if we're in war if we if
we have to be in all these bases what
ends up happening is that's our tax
dollars right so they petition for more
of a budget
they spend the budget and they go oh
we're in war we need more right then the
budget gets higher if you don't spend
the full budget what ends up happening
is your budget gets decreased because
it's like okay now we can use this on
education or all these other things so
the military-industrial complex how do
they make money from taxpayer money and
getting all of the contracts from the
government and all the inner workings
and dude and what used to happen is the
democrats used to say
[ __ ] bush and cheney we don't want your
wars and now that's gone for some reason
it's gone i don't know where those guys
went there's a couple of them left i
love all of them but the ones who aren't
the but there's not even ten percent so
that's what's that's what's wild about
it it's like for some reason there's
this pernicious um right and left thing
going on where they just completely
agree
they disagree very publicly with each
other you know but then all of a sudden
when it comes to voting time they all
completely agree they pass it and then
we all go to war again so go figure i
was saying russia's bad earlier because
we shouldn't go to war with russia
because they'll have a leg up on us
because i don't know if you guys know
this they've they've sent like children
here like young people and they grew up
in america but they're they were trained
in the formative years of their life to
be spies oh manchurian candidates
yeah absolutely because i saw the
documentary salt and i i believe firmly
that that's what happened charlie's
there right now
julia roberts julian roberts tv show
called like the americans or something
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but i i firmly
believe that happens but there was also
you know you remember um al qaeda right
the biggest threat that we've ever faced
but there were young arab men being
arrested they were like 18 19 years old
like after you know 9 11 happened these
guys are being arrested as terrorists
and they have done nothing wrong they
are being arrested for traveling
like for traveling and they're getting
charged with terrorism and because they
maybe contacted somebody in pakistan or
somebody in in one of these countries
that are one of the evil countries and
so now they get thrown away and nobody
cares actually you know what people go
yay we got another terrorist off the
streets that's [ __ ] fantastic biden
just blew up um you know some isis guy
but they took out children and women in
the battle as well and everyone over
here just goes
yay good i'm glad we got another isis
guy it's just wild well number five
biden this morning said though that it
was the guy the isis guy that blew
himself up that killed the kid that
killed the kids so he's not saying that
our drone strikes did it no we no we
don't kill children no we don't we've
never done that i don't know if you what
you were talking about was in the drone
strike program in the military and uh he
he just everything was on the up and up
he says he says was really super great
no we had the thing we had the
technology that like when a missile sees
children it moves that's right oh so
when it bombs the whole village they go
around the kids yeah yeah it's very safe
it picks up the children draws them off
and comes back oh
it sees the kid and it actually just
like goes up in the sky and it goes into
their mouth
it's more humane
but no they all i mean dude like i've
heard about um they took out a van of
just a family traveling
and then they're like oopsie daisies
that's the big time oofy doofy's we're
sorry and then they're like well um
actually we didn't take out innocent an
innocent family what we did was we took
out
um enemy combatants so they just
reclassify in the field of war which you
can do it's pretty easy and that's what
that's how they reclassify things which
you can watch you see like all of a
sudden obama gets elected president you
see the amount of civilian casualties
from drone strikes drops off the face of
the earth all of a sudden because they
just reclassify that [ __ ] this is why i
don't i don't want us to go to war with
north korea
because um manzanar
right now they think oh that'll never
happen again with like
japanese people what's manzano manzanars
where they uh the internment camp the
japanese internment camp during world
war ii and they actually had a platoon
made from the japanese americans and
they fought in world war ii to show that
they're loyal you know that they're
american citizens
but that could happen any time it won't
happen now but what do you think
guantanamo is with like with the for the
middle eastern people like our buddy
nadeem he right after 9 11 he said every
time he travels even up until like five
years ago he would always get stopped by
random searches random
that's why like if we go to north korea
i'm not going anywhere
i'm not going anywhere because i'll be
like hey you're north korean like why
people ask that now think oh you're
korean are you nor from north or south
i don't know if you're trying to be
funny or you're just ignorant like no
one can leave but you cannot leave north
korea one answer is funny than the other
though that's true that is true
somebody asked me that in mexico one
time
you from china or north korea and i was
like those are the options
china or north korea i was like most
people would have said philippines maybe
you know china or north like north korea
i'm from north korea he's like oh cool
and you know if we go to war with korea
they're going to round all of us up yeah
and you know who's going to tell on us
i can't wait
listen i'll tell on him first i'll tell
anthony leave first i'll go there's a
[ __ ] dancer you guys gotta check out
you gotta investigate and if you find
nothing to investigate him again because
he moves he gets moved
he's gonna dance his way out of out of
it all remember when get when gitmo got
closed oh wait it didn't you know what i
mean like it's just all this is a joke
it's just political theater bro it's
just political theater
you